You have probably heard that avocado is a healthy fat.
That is true, and it is also the least interesting thing about it.
Because the most powerful thing an avocado does has almost nothing to do with the avocado itself.
It has to do with whatever else is on your plate.
Here is the claim I want to prove to you.
If you eat a large, colorful salad with a fat free dressing, you are throwing away most of the nutrition in it.
Not some of it.
Most of it.
Let's follow the food.
An avocado is roughly fifteen percent fat, and most of that is oleic acid, the same fat that dominates olive oil.
It also carries a large amount of fiber, and almost no sugar.
In the stomach, that fat does something immediately.
Fat slows gastric emptying.
The stomach releases its contents into the intestine more gradually, which is part of why avocado is unusually filling for its size.
Then the mixture reaches the duodenum, the first section of the small intestine.
And fat arriving here triggers a hormone called cholecystokinin.
That hormone does two things.
It signals the gallbladder to contract, squeezing out stored bile.
And it tells the pancreas to release lipase, the enzyme that cuts fat molecules apart.
Now watch what bile actually does, because this is the center of the entire video.
Bile salts are unusual molecules.
One end of them is attracted to water.
The other end is attracted to fat.
When they meet fat droplets in your intestine, they surround them and break them into microscopic spheres called micelles.
Water loving surface on the outside, fat loving core on the inside.
A micelle is a delivery vehicle.
And it is the only way a fat soluble molecule can cross the watery layer lining your intestinal wall and reach the cells that absorb.
Here is where your salad comes in.
The color in vegetables is not decoration.
Carotenoids are the pigments that make carrots orange, tomatoes red, and spinach deep green.
Beta carotene.
Lycopene.
Lutein.
Every one of them is fat soluble.
They refuse to dissolve in water.
So if you eat a salad with no fat on it, there are no micelles waiting for those pigments.
They travel the length of your intestine, past every absorbing cell, and leave your body essentially untouched.
You ate them.
You never absorbed them.
Add avocado, and the entire situation changes.
Its fat drives bile release, micelles form, and the carotenoids from every other food on that plate load into them and get carried to the intestinal wall.
Inside the absorbing cell, something happens that surprises most people.
These fats and pigments are not sent straight to the liver through the bloodstream, the way sugar is.
They are packed into large particles called chylomicrons, and those particles are too big to squeeze into a blood capillary.
So they enter the lymphatic system instead, travel up through your chest, and only then empty into your bloodstream near your heart.
Your salad takes a completely different route through your body.
So what does the evidence say?
This one is unusually clear.
In controlled human trials, adding fresh avocado to a salad increased beta carotene absorption several fold, and lutein absorption rose sharply as well.
When avocado was added to a tomato salsa, lycopene absorption increased substantially.
Adding avocado oil on its own produced a similar effect, which tells us the mechanism really is the fat, and not something exotic hidden in the fruit.
On the gut itself, the fiber in avocado does shift the bacterial community and increases fat excretion in stool, and that has been measured in randomized trials.
But be careful here.
Those changes are real, and they are modest.
Anyone promising you a transformed microbiome from one fruit is selling something.
So, four rules.
One.
Do not eat avocado alone if you can eat it alongside vegetables.
Its real value is unlocked next to color.
Two.
Stop using fat free dressing.
It is the most wasteful habit in healthy eating.
A fat free dressing on a carotenoid rich salad discards most of what you paid for.
Three.
Do not scrape the flesh clean and throw the dark layer away.
The dark green flesh immediately under the peel carries the highest concentration of carotenoids in the whole fruit.
Four.
You do not need much.
A modest amount of fat, in the range of half an avocado, is enough to drive micelle formation.
This is not an argument for eating four of them.
Two quick notes.
Avocado is energy dense, so if you are managing your weight, the amount matters.
And if you have a latex allergy, avocado is one of the fruits that can cross react, so be aware of that.
None of this was really about an avocado.
It was about a delivery vehicle built out of bile, and the simple fact that a nutrient you do not absorb was never really a nutrient at all.
So which molecule should we follow next?
Write a food and an organ in the comments, and we will take it apart, cell by cell.